breaking overnight the CDC is confirming
a 13th case of corona virus in the US
this time in San Diego the patient was
on a government chartered flight last
week from Wuhan the Chinese city at the
center of the outbreak today China
announced the single day death toll from
the virus exceeded 100 for the first
time the number of deaths worldwide is
more than a thousand Carter Evans is
outside March Air Reserve Base in
California where the first Americans to
arrive from Wuhan are set to be released
from quarantine Carter what do we know
about this new case well that new case
that patient from San Diego was
initially mistakenly released from
isolation back into quarantine after
testing negative for the virus well
they're back in the hospital now said to
be doing well as for those 195
passengers who landed here last month in
March Air Force Base they're ready to go
home today
after passing one final health Jackie
and Thompson is ready to get back home
to his family in Detroit it's been two
weeks since he landed back in the u.s.
from the epicenter of the corona virus
outbreak but not everyone who flew back
from Wuhan was so lucky yesterday the
13th case of corona virus was confirmed
in San Diego a patient who arrived on a
u.s. chartered flight last week but
President Trump remains confident the US
has a handle on it I think it's gonna
all work out fine rough stuff I tell you
a rough rough stuff but I think it's
gonna work out good around the world
fears of transmitting the corona virus
are growing by the day in Beijing an
eerie emptiness set in during the
morning rush hour
officials there ordered citizens coming
back from the epidemic zones to
quarantine themselves for at least two
weeks in Hong Kong authorities evacuated
a residential high-rise after two
tenants who live on different floors
contracted the virus thousands of others
remain quarantined on
very basis is good for have a break
fresh air he's already fresh now and on
cruise ships like the diamond princess
docked in Japan which has been on
lockdown for a week the World Health
Organization is now on the ground in
China it will assemble a team of global
scientists this week in an effort to
speed up the development of treatments
and vaccines we may see numbers like in
any epidemic go up and down in in coming
days what really is important rather
than making predictions is really to
work hard to try to get solutions the
CDC is still testing nearly 70 people
here in the US who are suspected of
having the virus that includes another
person in San Diego who was on that
flight from Wuhan who is now exhibiting
symptoms Gale very scary stuff thank you
very much Carter